all right let's not spend a lot of time
on this and much of what we're talking
about today is developing live
and so I'm going to do the best I can to
tell you what's happened over the last
24 hours and then we have to move
relatively quickly to the next steps in
this indictment of Donald Trump but
Donald Trump last night
exploding on Truth social making it
clear he's terrified and making it clear
he doesn't actually care about Law and
Order demanding the indictment of Alvin
Bragg with what evidence on What charges
wait a second I thought your whole
problem was that this indictment of you
isn't Law and Order but now you're just
calling for the on a whim indictment of
the guy investigating you Trump trothing
to Troth Central quote wow district
attorney Bragg just illegally leaked the
various points and complete information
on the pathetic indictment against me I
know the reporter and so unfortunately
does he this means he must be
immediately indicted
what now if he really wants to really
clean up his reputation he will do the
honorable thing and as district attorney
indict himself there you go
he will go down in judicial history and
his trump-hating wife will be I am sure
very proud of him Trump not stopping
there with random demands for people to
be indicted continuing to talk about
special prosecutor Jack Smith
trophing quote speaking of leaks special
prosecutor Jack Smith what did his name
used to be leaked massive amounts of
information to the Washington compost
this is illegal and I assume this
radical left lunatic much to the Chagrin
of his trump-hating wife and family will
be prosecuted he is a totally biased
capital T Thug who should be let loose
on the Biden documents hidden in
Chinatown and the 1850 boxes secretly
stored in Delaware which Biden refuses
to give up Biden is guilty of
obstruction I am not so think of it
claiming that the problem here is that
Law and Order isn't being followed in
the investigation and indictment that he
is now subject to but on a whim within
just a couple of hours on Truth social
truth sensual I don't even know what
it's called at this point Trump demands
the self-indictment of Alvin Bragg
demands the indictment of special
prosecutor Jack Smith and declares Joe
Biden guilty of crimes absent any
evidence nor any criminal proceedings of
that sort and this is just another
reminder my friends they say they are
for Law and Order but they are not they
say they are for due process but they
are not they are for whatever is
convenient at the time as applied to
them and then whatever is convenient at
the time as applied to their political
opponents and if those two things
require a complete cognitive dissonance
and a divorce from any stated principle
of consistency then they don't care and
you know what they get away with it
because as many of you have written to
me and said David
the right doesn't care about hypocrisy
anymore the right doesn't care about
double standards so it's not even worth
pointing them out to them because they
aren't phased it's whatever is
convenient for me and not for thee and
that is it well we are going to learn
very quickly
indeed what the repercussions are of the
crimes with which Trump is Accused this
is only the first indictment today it is
now being circulated that another
indictment in Georgia could be coming at
the end of April which we will talk
about tomorrow these are truly
unprecedented times not because anybody
in the uh investigative Community has
done anything wrong but because we are
now starting to see accountability for a
unique and unprecedented one-man crime
spree that was the former president
Donald Trump
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for 20 off the link is down
below